-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind, we're
going to get to the news.
White House officials
are reportedly planning
to downplay President Biden's
upcoming 80th birthday.
Well, good luck with that,
'cause everything about Biden
screams "birthday week."
"Monday, I'm going bowling
with my college buds.
Tuesday, shots.
Wednesday's Dave & Busters,
then we're all flying to Ibiza."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden's granddaughter
Naomi is set to get married
next month at the White House,
though if you're trying to make
people to forget how
old you are,
maybe don't advertise
that your granddaughter
is getting married.
[ Laughter ]
According to a newly-obtained
audio, house minority leader
Kevin McCarthy told two
police officers
in a private meeting that former
President Trump
didn't know that his supporters
were attacking the Capitol
on January 6th.
And the only possible way I'd
believe that is if he didn't
know this was the Capitol.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] "I thought it was
a Medieval Times.
I thought it was
a Medieval Times."
[ Normal voice ] Election day
is four weeks away.
Said Biden, "Uh, well, then
we're also giving everyone
in jail for a weed 40 bucks."
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk discussed his
estranged daughter
in a new interview and added,
"I have very good relationships
with all of the others.
Can't win them all."
Hell, some people
can't even count them all.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The Northeastern University
School of Law mistakenly sent
acceptance e-mails recently
to nearly 4,000 applicants.
Even worse, Harvard Law
accidentally sent
an acceptance e-mail to someone
whose dad didn't even go there.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according to a new
ranking of fast food chains,
Chick-fil-A has the slowest
average drive-through
experience, while the fastest
drive-through experience
is McDonald's when all you
order is ice cream.
"Yeah, one ice cream cone
please?"
"Sorry, it's broken."
"Bye!"
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.